hey guys this is andrew for
tradingsensors.com so i've been working
as a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong on the option
market and i've just
started to make some youtube videos
where i want to show you guys all the
different tools and techniques that i
use at work to make money on the markets
so i mostly talk about technical
analysis in my videos because this is
for me very important it's like a
survival kit
that you guys need if you want to do
some training at least some day training
and for long-term investment
it is very helpful to find the entry
levels or where to buy the dip
but in this video i want to talk about
what i know the best which is
options and show you guys what you can
do using
options to make some nice and profitable
strategies
on amc let's get into it
[Music]
let's recall what is a call a call and a
put
it's the basic two vanilla options that
you guys can find everywhere
and so a call is something that is
giving you an upside performance
for a premium so for example this is a
payoff of a call
so here you are having a call guys
okay this is a payoff of a call this is
a 12
strike call i'm gonna use the maturity
of june because this is the most liquid
expiry on amc
i'm going to show you where you can find
all the information it's here
yahoo finance options all right guys
this is
the best database for options even for
the stock prices you know this
yahoo finance database is very complete
and here it's not even a database is
just the market
data all right you have all the market
data live market data
for free guys i mean it's close to close
but it's very good to use to build up
your strategies
so you select your maturity here guys
18th of june
and for example we are going to check
what is the 12 goal price
so guys the price is the mid between bid
and ask all right bid is the price
market makers are buying ask is the
price market makers are selling
if you want to buy you are gonna
probably buy the ask
level because you need to lift the offer
to get done
but actually if you put an order between
the bid and the ask you
usually have some iceberg orders that
are hidden here this is the option
markets guys this is the professional
market
all right so it's a market where you
need to trade the minimum size
of the multipliers hundred so you need
to buy at least 100 shares equivalent
all right so it's kind of big nationals
but for imc which
price is actually low it's okay it's
accessible so you guys probably can go
there
and here you can see that the 12 strike
call
price for the june maturity is between
120 and 129 all right so let's say 125.
so this is where you find your prices
then you put
your strike price here i did a very
basic spreadsheet guys where i can just
choose the quantity let's say you buy 10
options
all right so it's 1 000 shares the price
is 1.2 the volatility is 125
and you have your call price that is
like this now let's see a put price i
just checked the price is the same guys
so now if you buy
puts instead of buying calls
this is the payoff you are having all
right a put
option is a payoff that is giving you
money at maturity if the spot price
finished
below your strike level this is the from
the max
zero strike minus spot now what you guys
are probably having right now is a
payoff that is like this
okay so basically having shares so let's
say amc is at 10
i'm just gonna round this to 10. imagine
you have 100 shares
so if amc goes to 30 you make so you
probably have more than this guys
because amc is cheap so let's say you
have
1 000 shares so if amc is going to 30
you are making 20 000 us dollars now
what i want to show you guys
is that you can get actually the same
kind of performance
for low risk what is your risk here your
risk
is that on the downside you can lose 10
000
us dollars all right if amc goes to zero
i know stocks don't go to zero is just
theoretical you can lose ten thousand
you can make twenty thousand
now instead of doing that guys all right
so here i put zero now you don't have
anything you can buy
ten cool options so if you buy ten cool
options it will cost you one thousand
two us dollars all right so this is the
money you can lose if amc
finishes below 12 on the 18th of june
and on the upside you're making actually
the same money a little bit less all
right if we go to 30 you only make 17
000 so i guess so you buy 12 and
you're gonna make the same all right now
you're making 20 000 again if we go to
30 but it costs you 1 400 us dollars
but you cannot lose more than this
basically your loss
is capped so this is what is go good
about call options you have the same
upside performance
only until june of course i guess this
is a premium you're gonna pay
for three months even two months of
course if you want to keep doing this it
would cost you more
that's why i have a solution for that
you need to
finance your premium all right this is
what professionals do
i'm an option trader so basically every
day i do prices for clients so clients
are asking me
i want this type of performance and i'm
gonna give them what they want
so i'm gonna propose some usually zero
premium structure they don't like to
spend money
they prefer to bear some risk so here
what i would suggest
if i was in this situation i would look
at the chart
go check my video on amc i did yesterday
or two days ago
uh i'm bullish but i have a support
level at 750 that
i consider it's possible we go there all
right i mean everything is possible but
it's a scenario that
has some not close to zero probability
for me
but i don't think we're gonna go below
that so what i would advise
in this situation if i have this type of
view
i would say all right you're not scared
to lose any money if we go below
eight so piano profile that looks like
this is actually fine for you
because you only start to lose money if
we go below eight
so you can sell some put options and
you know you buy cool options you sell
put options
so basically between eight and twelve
you're making zero i checked the eight
put
strike is actually has the same price as
the 12 call
strike so those two are actually
financing each other i mean the put you
are going to sell is gonna finance the
call you're going to buy
so basically this is a zero cost trade
but instead of paying
money you take some downside risk below
the strike that you can define if you're
not comfortable
with eight you can choose five but of
course it will be
cheaper so you can do something like
this and here it probably google
15 the price is gonna be 0.6
so the situation is the same only you're
not making
money between 5 and 15 but you're not
losing money between 5 and 15 as well
i don't like this one i think that the 8
could strike is actually better
and here you can see that the maximum
loss you can have
is a bit lower we are only at 9600
we used to be at 10 000 so we actually
losing less money if we go to zero we
don't lose any money
if we go above eight and we are making
the same money on the upside
so guys i just showed you that instead
of having shares and you can
roll this strategy you can do it on june
and if it didn't happen
in june you can do the same with
september maturity and then with
december
and you know you can do it you can roll
it through the next maturities
whenever the expiry is coming this is
actually what protraders are doing
all the time guys we build up strategies
and we roll them until they're making
money
be careful with that the options are you
know
a bit complex instruments i'm gonna do
more videos where i'm gonna talk about
options i'm gonna try to show you guys
everything we can do you probably
understood that this is
very basic we can do much much more
complicated
and smart strategies let's start with
something that you know
is easy to put in place and to monitor
because then you need to monitor your
strategy this one is easy to monitor
because it's
zero cost risky so basically the payoff
is quite simple to understand
so once again guys this kind of strategy
helps you to rebalance your risk instead
of having a linear
risk like you had with your 100 options
so you can see the difference between
that
to that so it's just transferring the
risk to the areas
you feel comfortable to bear the risk so
guys that's it for me
i hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys